welcome um
to the william corbett poetry series
sponsored by the
comparative media studies program
uh
comparative media studies and writing
program at mit
uh my name is ed barrett
and tonight i had the pleasure of
introducing one of my favorite poets
charles north
charles has quite a uh
history of publications i'm actually
going to read from a piece of paper so i
don't leave
anything out
um
uh charles has published 12 books of
poems
uh including the recent everything and
other poems which was a new york times
new and noteworthy book
what it is like which headed npr's best
poetry books of the year
and the innovative baseball poem
poems complete lineups
uh it's one of my favorite collections
they're sly inventive imaginative
intelligent and
if i can even whisper the word
entertaining poems
they're delight
uh charles has also published three
books of critical prose
collaborations with painters most
recently elevenses with the
uh
noted new york uh internationally known
painter trevor winkfield
and co-edited the poet and painters
anthologies uh broadway and broadway two
with james schuyler
charles has received a slew of awards as
you would imagine
the foundation for a contemporary arts
grant two nea fellowships four fund for
poetry awards and a poet's foundation
award
he lives with his wife paula painter
paula north in new york city
uh please welcome charles north
thank you
this is
something of a special reading for me
and not only because as we were saying a
minute ago the invitation for it came
three years ago and had to be canceled
at least a couple of times
but it's a special reading for me um
i i hope this doesn't embarrass ed but
he's one of my favorite people
and also um
uh i was a long time friend
of bill corbett's uh for whom the series
is named so it's special in both it's
very meaningful for me on both those
counts
i also have some connections to the area
which i
am allowing myself to mention some are
on the tenuous side
but they're meaningful to me
i'm i'm from new york but i've been a
sox fan since i was eight years old
i went to tufts
and very very briefly to harvard law
school
my best friend in high school went to
mit
and i had an elementary school friend
who was the first person to get an mit
phd in philosophy
uh i remember him doing algebra in third
grade
this is an mit student
okay
um poets often begin with older poems
and work their way up i thought i would
do something a little bit opposite just
just for a change of pace and i i would
read a few um
poems from my recent collection and
mentioned everything and which is the
title poem and other poems and then uh
if there's time which i hope i'll read a
few um older ones which i haven't read
in a long time but that's that's fun to
do sometimes and i'm expecting it to be
something like a half hour
um if it isn't i'm sure it will step in
give me a virtual punch in the nose
okay so uh ed mentioned uh
a collaboration that um
that i did with my friend
the artist trevor wingfield we actually
have a um a newer one called alphas
which which came out um last year i
think but i'm going to read some
sections from the book
11s
my part is i like to think of it as a um
as a longish prose poem i'm not going to
read it at all i'm going to read parts
it's in the form of a diary but it isn't
really
sometimes it is sometimes it isn't it
isn't quite a diary
and and it's it's all
so this is from elevenses
um
which name i like trevor's was born in
england
and uh
your 11s is is your
11 o'clock coffee or a tea or pick me up
in the morning in england
i've always liked the word
okay
i'll read sections skip around
this is the beginning april 10 opening
day
so it's been proved time and time again
that few things close entirely
mouths
screen doors
seasons
parts
cases
bars
flies
i know mines plays arteries bookstores
june 22nd
the giraffe vendor stopped by and will
come back later
he seems nice
granting the difference between a wish
and a forward gesture
does a flashback constitute a new
element rather than a celebration of
continuity
is it like taking it from the top in
music
june 26th
speaking of names for new elements what
about equilibrium at 11 o'clock
not exactly a solid but by no means a
gas
can an emulsion be an element
wittgensteinium
stradivarium
june 29
tedium
linoleum hegemony ilium brooklynese
subfusk simulacrum granola
dopamine honorarium
epithelium
byzantium secretariat incunabula
preludium
exon saturnalia rustoleum leaf mold
fracture
plebiscite lager monadium parsimony
segovia
that it's a long list i'm stopping there
so i'm skipping ahead
june 30.
you can lead a paper wasp to a coffee
cup
but you can't know if circling the
rose-colored rim has anything to do with
the creative process
or if a rush of cool air storms a
previously unacknowledged barricade
it is after all only two weeks to
bastille day
rattling the edges of everything except
strictly speaking but doesn't happen
november one
some ideas are nearer and dearer than
others
the problem is how to make them
permanent and not just souped up for the
occasion
with the corollary that permanence is to
at least some degree a function of
souping up
take the one about daylight
supported by nothing until you and i
realize we're the ones chosen to carry
it
along with the grocery bags paper coffee
cups and a list of things that really
should be done by lunchtime
ideas that can't or won't adjust to the
times gust into oblivion without so much
as a blink
the seven civic dwarfs half the
bunkhouse horrocks and ferrex the hotel
to dream
the rooster crowing its head off
i'm scratching the surface
november 15
a smell of garlic
and the almost sun leans on a linden
tree affecting nonchalance
november 19
the silent e that looks back at you from
the ends of so many words
though i have a suspicion it doesn't
always do so happily
november 20
pale green celery leaves and the small
whitish hearts that signify narcissism
in the unmediated sense
but i only recently learned that
narcotic has the same root
which might explain to some degree
those mornings when fog for want of a
better term
is unrelieved
what is the good life
apart from focus on what is good about
it for as long as that lasts
absent which the notion has so little
content or connection to the conscious
self
that the smallest breeze or grinding of
breaks puts an end to it
of course horseradishes and turnips of
hearts too never mind artichokes
possibly macon apples with their short
season
whereas the outer directed eggplants
carrots kale tomatoes pumpkins etc live
healthy and useful lives reveling in
monopoly monopoly colors as do cars and
national flags
december 14.
the day after being scooped out of its
trough
mostly by hand but with some heavy
machinery too
was rolled out tarred cemented and
allowed to dry before traffic resumed
its normal morning flow on both sides of
broadway and the other north-south
arteries that define the west side
well it's true that names make
navigating easier it's also true that
most are merely pasted on
occasionally romantically involved with
their subjects
but more often creatures of habit or
even sheer impulse
this is the last section that i'll read
and the last one from the from this
piece december 17 note from yesterday
the rusted water tank was a cupola and
its imagined pendants at 4 pm
versus the screensaver
when encroaching darkness is the last
thing you want saved
one of the things a bloody mary clearly
has going for it is the color
more too of course but the free floating
passion
when used shaved ice a reminder of the
frozen sea within
in contrast to the physicalist celery or
explosiveness of explosiveness of
tabasco red darkened upon red
touches more deeply than mere alcohol
says you well i do i think who knows
not the moon swirling in the clouds of
its gray matter or the migraine is sun
suffused with an analytical cubism of
meanings in color and not
like a fireball hitting window hitting a
window pane
part of what i think is that texture
grain feel are days of the week
and the formal aspects that used to
count as bare bones reality scoop years
from the lives they're glued to there
goes one now
nothingness the sinfonietta they all
play in pauses just long enough for
space-time to get a word in
before the sun dips a toe into the glass
and the blood sprouts wings claws and a
beak and pushes off from its high-rise
perch for parts unknown to the perceiver
who perceives the redness that is not
before being blindsided by the redness
that is
this is a poem home
shortish
the title is kind of stolen from
felonious monk
it's called creeper school with paula
does realism get your vote it gets mine
the plants with their insatiable thirst
for appearances
the heart-stopping 7pm air moonlighting
as a pressed cardboard korean ashtray
server modest coaster
decorated with a single blondish branch
holding six leaves and a piece of
rose-colored fruit pear plum bright
peach
ripe pea
slightly raised as if applied to the
flat creamy space behind collect with
light gray light green and brown marks
of varying size from pinpricks to ashes
pencil it looks like to brush
the romance of the window panes i'm
squinting a little
has nothing to do with the misguided
view the one with the fates schmoozing
under the maroon awning of the high rise
schmooze
as chmos is more like it
and the embarrassed looking sycamores
revealing for all their worth in their
slightly fictionalized but emotionally
accurate way
which contributes to the overall tone
without detracting from the realistic
participation
a motorbike taking the corner a
motorbike taking the corner too fast
a cat knowing the worst that can
possibly happen
happen and managing to avoid it
which could be the key signature
if not for a freestanding radiance just
outside
unmoored a hint of plum or anju pair
um
the next piece is
i wrote for um a poet friend ron padgett
it's um it's called
french licks
uh licks i guess as in uh
jazz riffs at least i hope
um i like
the name of the town french lick there's
another connection to boston larry bird
one of the all-time great basketball
players
um which i remember was in my head when
i wrote it
so it's it's a it's a bunch of uh
quite short um
uh pieces that i translated and put
together in what i hope is a whole who
knows
ron padges is one of our great
translators from the french so um i did
this with some trepidation i had never
done any real translating before
what do you want me to say
that is picasso gaston larue carco
girodu admirals on shoreleaf gime museum
schools for everything under the sun
aragon santex gertrude stein fuel oil
people doing business deals soccer
rainer maria rilke everything i can
possibly think of leon paul farg
at one end of the bridge that squashes
the water underneath it the cop just
took out his ticket book
max jacob
even dead i'm an insomniac
jewel superville
oh night if only you didn't have ears
pouring out
i need i need better glasses
oh night if only you didn't have stars
pouring out there hackneyed phrases
i want emptiness blackness bare
nothingness charles baudelaire
the dog in the fireplace just woke up
the cat with a cigarette is purring in
front
it doesn't look like anyone needs a
drink
the wine is corked anyway
that odd hat covering your forehead
pointed and ugly
watch out your ideas don't leave when
you take it off
pierre verdi
bread is supposed to be eaten not only
honored in a poem francis
i did test working
lazy half asleep with the one hand not
buried under the covers i barely managed
to write you this poem barely
mark antoine girard de sant among
did anyone see the toad cross the street
he's tiny no bigger than a doll
going on his knees embarrassed not at
all
arthritic
he has to drag each leg ahead of him
where to
he came up out of a sewer pipe poor guy
not a soul noticed
it used to be that way with me
now they mock my yellow star
lucky toad you don't have to drag a
yellow star everywhere you go max jacob
i drizzle all over europe everyone's in
the same boat never mind the infantry
busy with their guns where the scary
newspaper headlines
constant drizzle making the flags go
limp jewels superville
your eyes aren't eyes they're gods
they hold sway over kings
did i say gods make it blue heavens with
the same flashings and dartings
heavens how about brilliant suns
blinding us to everything else
suns more like lightning bolts that give
a hint of the force of our love
this is a sonnet by the way
although i don't rhyme
the pain i feel couldn't come from a god
the heavens are one thing not two as for
the sun who doesn't know it's unique
sun rays they don't hold a candle to
your eyes
yet the false comparisons both shed
light eyes gods heavens sons and their
billions
honorar loggier de porscher
just before the bell of night when the
seasonal canvas ruffles and the sun
draws honey from the bodies of women in
bed and every ship with its vowels and
its incest sets sail solo to the shrill
flutes of europe
almost dawn and no one else around the
milkman's cans wake up the street
guillermo paliner
the future arrived but it's lazy
call valerie
i remember when winter coats i remember
what winter coats smell like
dogs running under the table
saucers clinking while cabinet ministers
fell
times anger pretty women's laughter
strewn on the floor like turtledove
feathers
the canon of theories designed to order
or else disrupt
handshakes indicating contrary states of
mind tumultuous and peaceful puffed up
subrosa unnoticed yet ringing with
health like a gothic steeple my own paul
fark
tall svelte locomotives speeding
effortlessly through the lonely serbian
mountains
followed by four yellow cars with gold
writing on them and beyond across rose
strewn bulgaria
valerie lorbo
it all comes down to time natural
for you too
we have to beat it at its own game if
you know what i mean beat it to the
punch
you know the one about the flea inside
the door i'm sure you do it makes
perfect sense
i really don't know what else to say am
i ever going to see you
or misho
um
i'm going to skip a few
the kings never even touched the door
so how can they possibly know how it
feels to push open one of these
two-dimensional friendly giants
forcefully or not or to return it to its
original position
holding it in one's arms
francis
pale muse after me again you ask way too
much it's like riding on sand in the
middle of a storm
i remember when i was young and poems
just came
but things have gotten tough
my instrument would snap like a reed if
i so much as tried
alfred de musee
the horses picked up pieces of a dream
huge red clouds mushroomed over the
public spaces even the small street
lamps swiveled their beacons to see as
for the future its lethal mosquitoes
wind and steamed in the gardens jimmy
cesar
i'll finish with three little ones i'm
skipping around it's not nearly as
enjoyable to write something down as it
is to erase it in one fell swoop like a
sudden storm
cut to black
francis
you ups and downs unfathomable pulse of
green seas the piece of grazing animals
and of the lines alchemy publishes on
students foreheads arthur vampo
to have all the words running around in
one's head and choose the plainest if
not the worst
and then start the celebration
jewel supervillain
okay uh
the last things i'm going to read from
this book
the title page is is very long it's the
longest thing i've ever written by far
about 30 pages long
i'm going to read the first section of
it there are four sections
and
i'm going to start it it starts in the
book
with something i titled study for
everything but the name of poem is
everything
and it ends with a coder so i'll read
the study for everything and then the
first section
study for everything
tenure schminer the sage is a role in
the hudson river pier
don't lean over too far
i wouldn't be surprised to see arms and
legs even a vital organ or two
representing the shy
passive aggressive inner life
brushing out followed by
brushing in
if people in high rises shouldn't groan
neither should the brownstones huddle
closer together each time there's a hint
of autumn in the air or in the trees
like if you'll pardon me for saying so
rushing to cremate the dead when
everyone themselves included
knows we want them around for as long as
humanly possible
not of course that the pangs have much
choice regarding where to settle or be
observed
a rusty hydrant is as good as a park
bench
the handful of pigeons poking around a
chunk of baguette near the grass don't
seem to agree
but they are hand stamped inks some line
too
already beginning to fade
i only know what i know is one version
another has witnessed so many royal
portraits
or the parade of experimental drugs for
a dread disease
is that knowledge works only some of the
time
really works
never mind how things seem as opposed to
how they see themselves
or why appearance stakes so much if not
everything on the distinction
okay
this is section one of everything
and um it starts with an epigraph by
george harriman
the wonderful cartoonist who did the
crazy cat which is one of the all-time
great
things
um and the epigraph is
everything is just nothing repeating
itself
one
stop me if you've heard this one
two llamas poke their heads out of the
small stone enclosure part of a garage
they spend their time in
when they're not taking the sun in a
tiny fenced in yard dotted with
wildflowers
just as we turned to look a small flock
of wild turkeys materialized out of
nothing and began squawking clearly at
us
who knew they were the concierge family
everything gusts
and then dies back down
at least as likely everything exists
inside a giant thought balloon which
rides continual gusts
although no one can possibly speak about
let alone contemplate the situation
as to the air outside the balloon
spangled with oak leaves and high strips
of white clouds
let's leave that one for now
as the beaver said to the log half in
half out of water
getting to annoy you
getting to know all about you
speaking of balloons the image i've
always liked from as far back as high
school is the lead one
successful as a lead balloon
it took off
like a lead balloon
the fact that it got off the ground at
all before plummeting with a thud if not
a loud crash
does a good job of encapsulating human
striving wedded to human failure
not certainly that the conjunction is
inevitably the case but the poignancy to
me anyway is palpable
as to the light from outside that must
penetrate the thought balloon regardless
of its color or degree of translucence
that too seems best left for later
like playing two sets of tennis
following a bout of pneumonia
or the view of niagara that nobody has
what did the 20-ounce bottle of perrier
say to the late afternoon sunlight
struggling to get indoors
the apartment building has more openings
than the sprawling cemetery on the way
to the dump up state
or the one littering the heavily
trafficked manhattan approach to the
robert f kennedy formerly triborough
bridge
you'd think the fumes by themselves
would be a discourager
you say tomato and i say everything is
consumed by its appearances
i've been instructed to push a handful
of minor characters back into the wings
but they won't go no matter how hard i
try
the pencil line between being and not
being hardly static however it looks
more accurately between staying put and
erupting into feelings that can't be
held in check no matter what
like the corruption built into medical
advertising aimed directly at the tv
viewing public
reminds me of the boundary line between
so-called feeling and so-called
understanding
to have a purchase on
know thoroughly by close contact with or
long experience of as opposed to hearsay
or even legitimate authority
as the great poet miakovsky sidestepped
at least some of the more sinister
aspects of futurism
only to fall victim to himself as well
as comrades who didn't mean nearly as
well as they should have
so time fights off just about every
conjunction those with palpable
connections to space as well as just
about any others you can name
there goes one now
no it's a bird batting by
in fact the sky
as well as steven's remark of the world
just prior to the onset of world war ii
in contrast to t.s eliot whom stephen
somewhat surprisingly singled out for
praise
is growing floppier
warped tent poles and stakes
an occasional scrawny pigeon on a wing
one roof garden with a flapping umbrella
which from the back looks like our lady
of the george washington bridge
but no cloud structure for support
unless you count the grayish wisps
barely clouds that hung around the
palisades for most of the morning
actually the view is appealing provided
it doesn't go decide to go too far in
the direction of floppiness and risk
falling over into the appearance of
whatever is holding it up a girder or
pylon or some idea of structure per se
that hasn't yet been instantiated
speaking of support i've had a hard time
forgetting about the guy in our building
who i used to see going for his run
every morning before breakfast
who jumped from his 10th floor window
and magically survived seriously broken
bones but alive
apparently because he landed in a tiny
courtyard on a bale of recycled
newspapers primarily the new york times
does that qualify as the ethical sphere
maybe just
yesterday morning just before i woke up
a few persons with backpacks and what
looked like metal maps several inches
thick were bobbing up and down on the
platforms that looked like on platforms
that looked like ice flows but more cork
than ice
every once in a while one of them went
over with a silent splash
suicide is one of the silent e words
but so are cope and rosette
in coet baseline nape
here's one how many singularities can
fit onto the head of a pin
pushed into the so-called bulletin board
of consciousness
quark again but not a real theme i'm
pretty sure
as distinct from the riptides sinkholes
tsunamis you name it occasionally just a
tone row or cluster that emerge
seemingly out of nothing to manhandle
the intention principle and hold on for
what can seem and in some days be hours
or even days
so how best to use one's time which in
one very large sentence everything
is at best a conundrum worth examining
and it works the exam and the dream with
all the silent percussion in the course
you've never signed up for
although everyone else is scribbling
away at their desks next to their green
lamps the line yap being somewhat on the
order of dusk an apparently new range of
colors intonations shapes etc which is
familiar
and also entirely out of the blue
okay i think i have five minutes
for my half hour so i'll read a few uh
just just a very few um older things
um
maybe four or four little things
by the way this is a covered by trevor
winfield
it's a tiny one it's called everything
keeps on happening
which is why they laminate the
newspapers
and put them up a few feet above the
calorie pear trees the only trees that
can silently read
for example a thick sheen like a sun
with a broken yolk
but what happens is that the numenol is
invariably the issue
throwing the switch awkwardly one way
and then rapidly the other so it's
impossible to say more than could be
said if nothing in fact were happening
so imperceptibly it feels awkward to be
noticing
and and this is an older one um
which was written uh for my daughter
who's a was a philosopher and this is
um
she she went to school in new jersey and
she teaches in new jersey
this is a little postponed called the
philosophy of new jersey
actually the sky appears older than it
is it's 63 or 64 at most not
75. the part with the cliff face and the
yellow crane could be in its early 30s
it wasn't wallace stevens who said
they have cut off my head and picked out
all the letters of the alphabet all the
vowels and consonants and brought them
out through my ears and then they want
me to write poetry i can't do it
it was john claire
well as stephen said something like the
best poems are the ones you meant to
write
that has a nice sound to it
but it's hard to see how he or anyone
would know that
it would be hard for example to accept
the notion that there are ideas one
meant to have
poems underneath every peeling sycamore
and inside every file cabinet along with
ideas about poetry and uncountable other
ideas
um
it mentioned the uh
poems and
strange poems in the form of baseball
lineups that um i started writing years
ago and
and um have done a bunch over the years
not all that many
um and about a dozen years ago i i
published
a book called complete lineups complete
was kind of a joke because it's a tiny
book
but anyway the idea was that i i
arranged all kinds of things that have
absolutely nothing to do with baseball
i'll give you some examples
um
into
baseball lineups
kind of like regular baseball items that
is to say in a batting order where where
a few bad
things have changed of course and since
i wrote most of these things
now it's better about second than fourth
when you used to have your best hitter
batting third or fourth
anyway it meant something about second
third or fourth and it was different
from batting seventh or eighth and it
also meant something to uh to play
center field and that was different from
playing second base anyway i arranged
all these things
um
for example philosophers
which as you probably could tell was one
of my first loves
um raw vegetables
tall people
um
what else
diseases they weren't all funny
and um
about two weeks ago
i came across um
a lineup that i had just about forgotten
about
which didn't make the cut for this book
i i never published it but i'm going to
i'm going to close with it it's it's a
different sort of lineup it doesn't do
what the other ones do but it was
written for a poet friend of mine
uh named bob hershan
who died about a year ago it was
dedicated to him
so i thought i would finish with it
there was a memorial for him about a
month ago in new york
there's a tiny story behind him
he was a great baseball fan i was a
brooklyn dodger fan until they left and
then a mets fan
and when he was a kid
he went to his first baseball game
which turned out to be the rarest of
possible baseball games a perfect game
thrown by the dodger pitcher
you know no hits runs or errors just
27 batters
and he got home and he told his father
and his father said ah
you don't know what you're talking about
it must have been a shutout
his father was apparently annoyed that
he hadn't been there
and bob wound up writing a poem about
the experience which is a very funny
poem
and he titled it with the dodger
pitcher's name which is one of the great
names not just in baseball
ed head
real name real perfect game
real dodger pitcher
so um
about a dozen i guess about a dozen
years ago
i wrote a note to ed head for bob
herschen
so um leading off and and playing right
field is don gullet
banning second and playing shortstop is
pinky higgins
center field batting third leo the lip
that was a nickname from leo derosher
who was
manager and player
adding cleanup and playing first base ed
head
batting fifth and playing third base
i'll read it the way he pronounced his
name although it's it's better on paper
jj puts
it it looks like putts
batting sixth i'm sorry batting sixth
and playing left field rolly fingers
batting seventh and playing right field
wally backman
catching nate
oliver
pitching no neck williams
i think his first name was walters his
name was
no nick
and i have five dhs
designated hitters hack wilson
lance berkman
horace stoneham
wait hoyt
and louis leckie
thank you
thank you charles
that was uh
a home run the whole evening
i really appreciate your time and and
joining us and thank you to all of you
who participated andrew thank you for
your technical help
uh and uh maybe next year we'll actually
be able to do this live in person
thanks again bye-bye